[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast please know that the
air conditioning is sort of not working
in studio today so I'm in a mood which
is why we're down to our skin
yeah I mean I was gonna be down to my
skins but then I remembered I'm a big
[ __ ] sausage so I had to put on this
cardigan on top of my skins which is
making me even hotter because air
conditioning is not working and I'm
about to cry so just let's go on with Sh
okay okay well we are just your favorite
skin ambassadors well one of us is well
no we are both on the skin story and I
was thanking the story on Friday nights
on Kim's story like she I put my phone
down for five [ __ ] seconds to watch
working moms and I get a call from
Jackie and she's like I'm like what's up
no yeah cuz I was writing in our family
chat like screenshotting and Kim's story
and I was just like dying of adrenaline
and I realized like 15 minutes later
that I hadn't heard from you I was
watching working mom so I FaceTime to
you and I could tell that you you had no
clue no I was like what's up so I told
her and I was shook and I was like a
part of it was like did I make it too
and then when I said like I'm so happy
for you talking around like it's so
happy but I was like just like tonight
oh no okay good no I'm just I'm happy
for our cam the morning shows made it on
like and the morning shows needed on and
let's say your stories were so pretty
I'm like they deserve to be made on
cheating she put Jackie in eight times
and then at one point she deleted so
when they're getting she posted me twice
and then when while we were on the phone
we like went to look at it again and it
wasn't there and I was like oh my god
she deleted me like she's embarrassed of
me like it's over we have a nice run at
least I have the screenshot to prove it
yeah and then I started getting
notifications Kim mentioned you in your
story like eight more time it was
obvious that she wanted to put your
whole series yeah and she like
reorganized her stories which is so Kim
we know because she's always like
deleting she's all organized see him
yeah and she like it's very careful
about her like slow and she likes when
things make sense so then she posted the
whole thing 99 slides the biggest
takeaways there's a few big takeaways
here one like Kim Kardashian saw the
morning toast yeah just like that
and they come on the show the millennium
morning show like she did see that okay
- my DMS are open with Kim Kardashian
and Jackie sent a nice sweet little
message I did
I'd like my Jam's are open with her like
it was so much pressure and as much as I
was so excited like I'm really not cut
out for this like I was the last ring
the thirst life is one in which I don't
feel you have the look the cojones yeah
or the thirst life so I like didn't know
what to do it's like I keep hitting
these notifications that she mentioned
me like - I heart everything go spawn
like I don't want him I don't want her
to turn me off right everybody in
general oh my god then I don't want to
not say anything and then she'll be like
oh this ungrateful [ __ ] right so after
a little bit of time and pass a message
shirt and it was like oh my god thank
you so much
I love skins and you Congrats blushing
emoji heart guys Kim responded responded
when she said it would hit me talking to
this girl to it but she said oh my god
thank you so much and thank you for
making the best videos makes me so happy
and by the way she uses more exclamation
points than I do
oh my god does she I use like two per
sentence and she uses three to four so
do I mean came up so much in common and
so it was just that's so crazy
and did you heart her message it and
because I didn't want to give her an
unnecessary notification like her time
is precious I don't want to bother her
so now it's just like we're in a good
place
this is step one for Kim on the trip I
mean what happened to you this weekend
it's just proof of what we've been
saying on the show forever and it's that
premium content always wins like yeah
tons of people got the PR package but
nobody nobody put together a dance
routine this show but like there was
tons of different you know influencers
doing I saw some shitty influencers
putting up some shitty blurring mirror
videos and I just want to say like that
is not the definition of premium content
if you try that on like there were so
many of those you just like did the
dress like yeah so excited to get my Kim
kardashian-west skin yeah that's what
they sounded like to me no that's really
what they sounded like so also another
thing side is this was the first PR
package I've received from Kim's camp
and like I feel as though I have
cemented myself as someone who will get
the next one a future endeavors I agree
what are you gonna do with the box like
I was excited about it now I'm like okay
it's really heavy like where the [ __ ] do
I put it I know it's in like the corner
of my bedroom like it's
cute so I'm just leaving it there and
even under like a stack of boxes like
that week you like what they should not
want on top yeah I just like I'm never
getting rid of it who are the nor the
shopping bag none of it and by the way I
freaking love my skins I wore them
Friday with like a little dress-up stay
I'm sorry on Saturday when I went
upstate and that's what's so crazy is
like God works in mysterious ways
because I was supposed to go craziest
part I was supposed to go upstate on
Friday at 2:00 and then we ended the
show the show was really long on Friday
as you all know I was wearing my Lola
tampons I was having cramps and the
weather like wasn't great and I was just
like not feeling great and I had two
hours to pack and get a manicure and I
was just like the exact I don't really
feel like driving upstate like in a
convertible in bad weather while I have
cramps like maybe we should just go
tomorrow and so we decided to go the
next day which left me open with time to
make a video of me dancing in my skins
which would have never happened if God
wasn't didn't make it rain and God
didn't give me cramps that's a thing it
always comes back to God right so it's
like the universe just won this so
Jackie and I are both wearing the skins
leotard time wearing a leotard which
it's definitely my favorite thing that
I've ever seen me to do I got it in nude
I wish I got it in black but I guess
I'll just have to order when it comes on
sale I'm wearing large extra-large what
sizes small medium and I just have to
say I put it on without a bra and they
were very supportive but you could see
my nipples through so I had to put on a
bra but I just think it's worth noting
that the elasticity can hold up these
jugs right that is an impressive feat
it's it's it's a scientific feat and
it's worth noting that the little shorts
that we showed on the show like to go
over a body oh my god wait
so I oh my god I wanted to kill Ben so I
was trying on my skin's and I was
putting in the leotard and it was it's
really elastic so like you step into
this tiny thing but it eventually
stretches and bends like let me help him
I stopped touching and he's pulling play
he ripped my skins you had to be really
careful I said get off like oh my god I
was so mad it was like a fight in our
house it's like smooth like butter which
is what makes it so comfortable to wear
but if you're my nails are really long
and raggedy like some nails
and I had to be really careful while I
was putting it on because you can like
easily make a hole in it yeah oh my god
I wanted to murder him yeah but he was
really funny in the broth somewhere he
thought it was about him he was like
take a picture it was funny yeah he's
funny he's very funny it was just a
crazy weekend like after that like how
could we
I know after that I would like head just
so much adrenaline anxiety my ears were
burning like I really felt like I could
feel the Kardashians talking about me
like it was just too much for me to
handle I go to sleep I was just like
like or like what do I do with myself I
know it and like just thinking about the
possibilities of like eat or video being
saved to Kim's camera roll like - Kanye
I see it like right like we're they know
she's like you say babe look at this I
don't know my ears were burning so much
that's what I thought was happening also
then like all the toasters were so happy
for me like I really felt like a win for
the whole everything like all 40,000
above in the morning toast group and all
hundreds of thousands of toasters who
are watching today we are now like one
giant step closer to possibly getting
Kim on the toes yeah like now it's not
like we are on her radar in some sense
and I just really felt like everyone was
so happy for me like it felt like really
a team win and that just made it even
better because I couldn't handle the
pressure of it all being me and now that
we're planning in LA we cannot - we're
like I think that should be our mission
you think not while we're in our studio
like on our turf like we're in some like
no I don't think we could ever get Kim
to come here I think whatever we do
we'll have to come to her oh I guess
they like go to her house and podcast
yeah or if we're in LA like chill come
to in LA studio but like I don't think
she's ever in New York let alone will
she come here she's she has a place in
New York no I mean but she's never
working in New York like she's always
just like with the kids at Kanye's place
at their place there said we're never
gonna go there no no no but maybe she
would like come to a show like she would
go do an interview I'm just trying to be
realistic you know I think we'd have to
come to her I would prefer to go to her
- would just bring like we get brand new
with that mentality it's like two huge
like there's monster fans into her huh
oh my god she let in all those thirsty
la influencers when she did that k'kaw
beauty event and they were in her
[ __ ] house
yeah actually where should I hit every
single one of them I was invited the day
before like that was a throwaway
imitation Kim you should have gone so I
couldn't lose only spent $3,000 on a
plane I mean on a flight for a day
before imitation I didn't know she was
gonna Instagram everyone yeah what would
you have done satire
I mean I would never have gotten invited
so like you know but like realistically
no it's yeah what it's too much more I
understand why you didn't go because was
day before
it was just like okay it's a cool event
but whatever but like having seen that
she put everyone on her story that it
was in her home and that would now do
you we show you mine
no no yeah no now obviously but the day
before I was like really thinking about
I was looking at JetBlue flights I'm
like am I gonna be this [ __ ] loser
that flies across the country and spends
thousands of dollars just like go to my
bed okay I'm like Kim's not even gonna
be there you know yeah I didn't know she
was gonna be Thursday like I am thirsty
yeah I didn't know the thirst was gonna
be reciprocated totally do I need
everyone to how many followers I've
gotten oh yeah netted about three
thousand it she's like it wow I just
need a few more and out I'm almost at 21
that's crazy because like you think that
like back in the day like if Kim I know
we were talking about with bed it's like
the algorithm and Instagram has changed
so much like if it's not the algorithm
because it's stories but it's also like
no it's just the way that like the
people use Instagram like evolved that
people are like so immune that like if I
feel like if Kim opposed you cheers
really we've gotten $100,000 but if she
posts me two years ago to her story
no like as an influencer it's not like
I'm she's posting her and her friend
right you know what it means so yeah I
think it's still really impressive I
think I made out okay I wonder how the
other influencers made out yeah I don't
think I mean I can't imagine they do
better but also I think if a lot of like
Kim Saleh where is they're looking for
like a certain look you know say
probably keeps my profile look know
you're looking for the Kim Kardashian
yeah but if I was a bikini model I think
I probably would have gotten more yeah
that's not who I am
no I mean literally now half the
influencers that Kim posted are like Kim
influencers yeah look they look just
like her and they wear biker shorts and
sweatshirts right and they post pictures
like her so like that's what people are
looking for yeah not like this girl and
her convertible and her grandma's scarf
no but it's different people asked you
for it oh for sure but like not a
hundred percent of the same audience Wow
what a weekend what a weekend and then
we went upstate busiest 24 hours of my
life because we could only rent the car
like for 24 hours otherwise it's a two
day rental so we had to return at the
same time we picked it up so it was a
full 24 hours went to cedar lakes estate
which by the way was so [ __ ]
beautiful and the owners to toaster and
I was talking her and she just runs an
amazing amazing ship it's a beautiful
campground that's where kambou who
copied camp toasts and had their event
yeah and I I see did she say anything
about Camp boohoo like being a total
ripoff of camp toast she did not she
said professional she said he's a class
act she's got to make that money right
but she was just they do a lot of
corporate events um and they do some
really cool stuff the wedding was so
beautiful it was so farm Shemin like but
classy Farber tremon like Theo she'd
totally get married there yeah and it
was just a really nice thing and I love
going upstate it was the perfect
distance from the city we rented over
convertible it was just like therapy you
know you wrote in the comments I don't
know if it's true that Kim's in New York
this week over Fashion Week nice a week
it's like when you're so famous like who
do you even email like when we book
guests like who have publicist assisted
it's like who do you email for Kim
Kardashian Kris no but she has public
the same publicist that sent us that no
but see that's like the skins I know but
like maybe they could put us in
connected dog yeah I just think Kim
would like really enjoy the show I think
so too
well you love the air conditioning fix
by them yeah I'm okay honestly I chose a
great day to wear skins really the
opposite I'm wearing like a parka
because I'm trying to cover my sausage
rolls and I'm feeling like I really wore
a t-shirt today or whichever like
brought why do you even need like merch
or us sitting around no I need you
change before we leave this house I mean
this building cuz
Jack and I recording off the vine with
Kaitlyn Bristowe today so that'll be fun
I shouldn't if I could show up in this
parka I like it but very cold like it is
pretty cold I bought this I wish I had a
part I bought this sweater for our trip
to Utah okay it shouldn't be worn in
September in the studio with no air
conditioner yeah I hear you thank you
I'm just really in a bit false here I
know I can tell them like no I'm just
like really I got no sleep I had a
hangover like you and your hangover it's
contagious I got used to be able to just
like play now with Chuck and rally
yesterday until I went to sleep I was so
nauseous so like for Klimt like I could
have thrown up at any minute and I'm
feeling a little bit better I'm just
like it's not it you know yeah well now
you know how I feel
I mean you'll be easier on me when
you're calling me a grandma because now
you're the grandma no I'm hoping this
isn't like the way that guy and I hope
this isn't just like the way I am I hope
it's not but it's a warning it's like
hey [ __ ] you're getting older just know
this is in your future but it'll take a
few years until it's like permanent this
is everyday because so like I was but I
drink at the wedding I'm like I didn't
feel horrible yesterday but then we woke
up we drove we didn't stop for food and
like by the time I got home I was like
so hungry not eating is your biggest
mistake I know but like we were just
making such good time there's just like
honestly it's quicker to just eat when
we go to the city and have better food
options and a rest stop even though rest
oh I know I'm the way up I had an egg
white wrap from Dunkin Donuts that was
so good
was it the impossible mean no it was
just a wrap with egg and cheese and it
was delicious
I'm happy for you had a fourth Mitch to
write three of us are just like not it
today I woke up sick this morning like
you know it is I feel like we've been
doing the show like steadily for a while
I'm like we've been on like many a day
in a row and between so many episodes
last week with guests and their guide so
much more going on last week like I just
feel like my heart's not in it today
oh I maybe I would have felt the same
way as you but Kim yeah can't be
postvention story and I would say I had
so much excitement adrenaline then last
night like Diplo reposted me and it's
just like all the integration into today
and like just the light was good up
saying and I'm just feeling good you
know yeah ya know I'm trying to you know
feel the same but I'm just you know it's
like well I feel as though it's 10:45 do
you do you think it's time I think it's
time I mean time to do on forever I
think it's time to deliver the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast it is time but in the
spirit of your vagina let's tell
everyone the importance of you Cora
because UTIs are very common
yes summertime you're running around in
a wet bathing suit all that juice is
flowing more than that cuffing season is
upon us and it's time for you Cora now
more than ever what season cuffing
season
what's up when everyone gets like cuffed
up in a relationship because the
weather's getting colder you've never
heard about this no um I gotta take the
cutest thing and it's so real like when
it becomes fall and winter like people
like they don't get in relationships but
they find
people like cuff up with to like snuggle
with and have someone to watch movies
with because the weather's cold like in
this summer you just like hot girl
summer you want to be left alone you
don't you don't want to be in a
relationship oh it's like the party's
over find a boyfriend yeah and like
maybe it's just for the season to keep
you warm through the cold winter nights
interesting okay well if you're like any
woman in America you get UTIs you know
that cranberry juice is useless and
taking too many antibiotics can be
problematic so what can you do try you
Cora the natural effective way to
prevent UTIs you Cora was developed
using the best research available in
collaboration with the team of
physicians their unique formula targets
bacteria and enables you to safely flush
bacteria out of your urinary tract
stopping UTIs before they can even start
mix it with water and drink it after
intimacy or exercise or wherever you
think you might be at risk of a UTI if
you don't know what causes your UTI
Zucco you Cora has you covered on a
day-to-day basis - it tastes like pink
lemonade with ingredients that are found
in nature so the special thing about you
Cora is that you can take it if you
don't have a UTI infection knowing that
it will actively prevent a UTI so
important I think that's that's pretty
special and pretty cool new korres
founders used to struggle with UTIs
herself so she knows what it's like to
be stuck in the cycle and that's why you
Cora has a money-back guarantee they
really want to help and if you aren't
happy with you Cora they don't want you
to be stuck with something you don't
want try it if you aren't happy within
30 days they'll give you your money back
you can try you Quora risk-free for 30
days and say goodbye to UTIs and right
now you Quora is offering 30% off when
you text toast to 48 48 48 but hurry
this is a limited time offer text TOA st
2 for 8 for 8 for 8 to get 30% off TOA
st - 48 48 48 sign on + p amazing yeah
okay first story a little fun New York
Fashion Week news that like isn't super
boring lisa rinna
Denise Richards of Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills hit the runway at New York
Fashion Week Kyle Richards was pretty
crying on the runway the real housewife
of Beverly Hills couldn't stop the tears
from flowing following her first
presentation for Kyle and shahida the
colorful new resort collection
co-created with designers Chiquita
Clayton luckily the television
personality had plenty of emotional
support five of her hello fellow Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills cast mates
including Lisa Rinna in a black soap
Denise Richards in a body suit of black
lace coupled with skin tight leggings
and Teddy Mellencamp in a sheer white
bodysuit pray to the label sultry
ensembles down the catwalk as statue of
her daughter Sophia and Alexia cheering
them on from the seats were two of her
new season 10 co-stars gar salvo and
sentence track along with her nieces
Paris Hilton and Nicky Hilton I saw I
think it's so it by the way genius
marketing move to have some of the
ladies walk uh-huh and I just loved like
watching a lot of them are former models
like I just loved watching them I don't
know like these are like they're like a
lot of like the housewife culture is
taking people like who were previously
famous or like were big mouths and I was
like they're reliving their glory days
yeah and they all just look really happy
to be on the runway and I thought it was
really cute and like a great business
move for Kyle Oh totally I'm like so
excited about this new venture for her
um they're obviously filming this for
the show so premium content also I just
want to clear up Erika Jayne was there
and like there was some fake news that
had been started like she took Beverly
Hills out of her clients ugly do you
ever have proof that it was there in the
first place I don't know that is the
definition of fake news she's clearly
still on the show and I'm so glad
because the women are in such a great
place and I think that this next season
of Beverly Hills like is gonna be the
one we've been waiting for it I'm really
excited about Garcelle um Wendy Williams
is on watch happens live last night did
you watch no it was actually so good and
I've been like very hot and cold with
Wendy Williams I used to like
ride-or-die for her and then she was
just like bothering me but now she like
took a lot of time off I think she's
very sober her divorce is in the process
of being finalized and she's the new
Wendy so she was the new wendy was on
watch what happens live and it was just
a great episode I wish that they had
spoken more about Titus Burgess
going on Wendy and talking [ __ ] about
Andy like that whole drama was crazy how
much our happens live but the drama
continued on her show but didn't talk
about it I feel like that it gives Annie
a pit no I think Andy was the one who
didn't want to talk about it yeah
because it's like it wasn't really a
good look for I tried calling in I was
calling Bravo like a million times I
wanted I really wanted to know I know
I'm sure it was like we're not gonna
talk about it yeah because it was kind
of fit in news
you know yeah well wendy was great
except she was running these sneakers
that's just like did her no favors and
they were like so ugly and like you know
what watch happens live it's so much leg
like with the seats it was just not a
good wardrobe choice but then she had a
producer Bart I'm like she really was
being like sort of a huge bone you know
oh that's really nice our fifth story is
about Wendy and her new dating life oh
but back to Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills so Kyle and Eileen closed right
Kyle by Alene yeah but to the online
e-commerce site close I don't know so I
like is this a totally new separate
venture this is definitely a totally new
separate venture because now she's a
designer that's cool that which is cool
and she always is wearing these what are
they called
the kimono kimonos yeah there was a
threat on Twitter of like people being
like Kyle's like ugly blouse collection
and they had like four random episodes
of like her wearing like not the cutest
shirts but it was like stating facts
that like Kyle is the worst style when I
think she's great style
oh my god she has been on television for
over ten years like being filmed every
single day like there's gonna be a
couple dogs in there no right and like
styles trends change no but you could
take anyone pick like they're for worse
looks and gray they have bad style but
overall her style is not controversial
at all no but look about her where she
first of all dresses age appropriately
you know she hasn't tried to be someone
that she's not agreed and she dresses
like comfortably like a mom but also
stylish Lee so I think actually she's a
perfect person to start a clothing line
like meteo actually I need you know more
about shahida yeah me too
what's her background the real fashion
expertise you know or like the men the
overseas manufacturing you know getting
the costs down yeah that's so important
cost is everything I've learned from
shark tank but actually speaking of
design that's a great segue into our
next story which is really sad sorry and
the one oh my god I know the story is
very sad - it's very sad show yeah sad
show Project Runway alum Chris March is
dead at 56
beloved Project Runway alum and Bay Area
fashion designer Chris March has died he
was 56 years old the cause of death
according to TMZ was a heart attack the
designer suffered on Thursday afternoon
March who originated from California
served as the longtime costume designer
for the musical revue Beach Blanket
Babylon before appearing as a contestant
on season four of Bravo's hit fashion
design series a fan favorite he also
made subsequent appearances on season
four of Project Runway also
and Project Runway All Star Challenge
marks went on to create custom pieces
for celebrity clients such as Beyonce
Meryl Streep Lady Gaga and Madonna she's
so sad I feel like he was very sick for
a long time and I remember a little
while ago and he was like talking about
I want you up inside like asking
everyone to pray for him because he was
like in really bad health so I actually
had thought that he had passed away when
that happened but I guess I just like
got my dates confused and I heard this
news I was so sad like this is who I
remember I watched the season he was so
cute like so happy always had a smile on
his face and like there plenty of
contestants who were on watch who are on
Project Runway and Angie never they knew
their aim or gave a [ __ ] about them like
he was special yeah he was special he
was definitely topped here and I think
what you're getting confused with is
June 2017 he suffered a debilitating
fall in his apartment
oh and had to be put in a medically
induced coma for two months yes that was
it so this is just really sad for the
whole fashion community and his family
and friends it's a loss it is a loss and
I feel like if I ever made it I would
have asked for Chris March to like
designs one of my looks for the Oscars
because like feel like he knows how to
dress a woman with roles you know mm-hmm
salsa trills the best kind rolls okay
muffin tops back fat you know we're
gonna get into our next sad story so we
can just I like honestly I hate talking
about sad stories thank you
well so last week a up-and-coming
country artist Kylie Ray Harris had died
in a car accident like so sad but now
more news is coming out about the crash
and it turns out that Kylie Ray Harris
caused the car crash that killed her and
a teenager please say in addition to
that which is just so sad was snitch was
telling us that the teenager who died at
the scene the EMT who came to like uh
answer the call answer the call was the
teenagers dad and that's how he learned
about his daughter's death which is just
like the saddest thing is ever say over
can you imagine no like going to a call
and then you're like wait so what does
the report say about her so involvement
the ex Tyler Harris is responsible for
Wednesday's fatal car accident that
killed her and a 16 year old female the
Taos County Sheriff's Office has claimed
authorities identified local high school
student Maria Elena Cruz as the sec
victim in the three-vehicle crash which
took place in northern New Mexico on the
evening of September 4th in a statement
obtained by Taos news Taos County
Sheriff Jerry hug Rafe said at this time
I will say with most certainty that miss
Cruz was an innocent victim of this
senseless crash caused by miss Harris
was miss Cruz in the car with Miss
Harris or in another motorist Cruz is a
16 year old and another cone another
yeah but was anyone in the car with her
when ohiolink so okay speed is
reportedly being investigated as a
possible contributing factor in the
crash according to the outlet
authorities also suspect alcohol played
a role in the accident
an investigation is currently underway
so we will leave it at that until the
investigation is complete
oh no mm-hmm terrible terrible terrible
story when something like this happens
it's like a someone who just like it's
like someone hearing the story I'm not
involved and you find out like that you
know this terrible accident happened and
like it was an accident or that it was
like a drunk driving something like do
you feel better like um I guess you feel
better because it's like okay and weak
you you see how it's preventable but
then it's also like cheap died in this
car crash it's coming out that it was
her fault and it's like it feels weird
to speak ill of the dead where and like
put the blame on her you know me so it's
it's conflicting right it's like very
easy to blame Chris soules for the cabin
throw share of it all because Chris
soules got to walk away live yeah and so
he can take the blame but like this girl
has died too
it's sad no matter how you slice it I
mean it's it's sad to put it all on her
and just like I great disgrace her name
like that you know that's so true yeah
that's also like what people say about
Michael Jackson you know like you can't
talk about the things that he did like
he's dead like let him rest in peace you
know but like what if you did do it you
know no I don't know I'm not comparing I
don't know that way about know about it
that's like the general consensus about
like when I searched Michael Jackson on
Twitter it's like can we just let him
rest in peace I feel like all people do
it like there's you know who wants rest
in peace those little boys try to just
sleep over out and never Neverland Ranch
sure but I feel like there's a
difference between someone who just
passed it were like days you know yes
he'll war
versus like a few years versus now I
feel like everyone who died like 50
years ago people talk mad [ __ ] they're
like oh you know like he [ __ ] his
sister right you know who I don't know I
feel like everyone's talking [ __ ] about
Elvis recently Oh cuz Elvis like did
date or like an 11 year old I think like
something like that yeah exactly but and
that's okay to say because it's like so
far gone right right like you wouldn't
say that about someone who passed away
last week oh it's like what I think
fresh I understand yeah I understand so
that's how I feel okay did you watch an
outsize epitome I know I just started
watching it this current season and then
I'm also watching season one because TPG
is just like telling me how much I'm
sleeping on Karen huger
and I just want to talk about it but I
guess I'll have to find someone else to
talk about I mean you could talk about
it in our TV boot cap segment okay
because I just like have thoughts on
some of the wives okay I look forward to
hearing them okay our next story is Elsa
oh my god what is going on Little Mix is
Jesse Nelson was attempting suicide over
cyberbullying this is so [ __ ] sad
Jesse nelson attempted suicide after
being targeted by online trolls the
Little Mix star opened up about her
experience in a new BBC 3 documentary
called Jesy Nelson odd one out as fans
will recall miss Nelson audition for The
X Factor in 2011 while she auditioned as
a solo artist she was eventually put
into a girl group with Little Mix with
Jade LeAnn and Perrie Edwards during one
of the episodes advancing a cover of
Nicki Minaj's super base they then get a
backstage to watch their performance on
YouTube quote I was very naive she told
The Guardian in an interview published
Sunday I thought it would be people
giving their opinion on our performance
but nearly every comment was about the
way that I looked quote she's a fat ugly
rat how is she how has this girl got in
the group how is the fat one in this oh
my god this is awful soon Nelson became
obsessed with reading people's comments
could I had a routine of waking up going
on Twitter
searching for the worst things I could
about myself I type in the search for
our jesse fat or jesse ugly and see what
would come up
she told the newspaper sometimes I
didn't even need to do that I just write
jesse and then see I'd see all the
horrible things everyone told me to
ignore it but it was like an addiction
oh my god what platform did they say
that they would did it on Twitter
um YouTube was the video that she saw
where people were commenting on her and
then she got addicted to looking at
Twitter to see what mean things people
to say where do you think is like the
nastiest platform for trolls not like
like Twitter's bad like fur like
reporters like here's the thing I think
Twitter is the worst because it's like
trolls in sheep's clothing where it's
like reddit you know what you're
anonymous you know you're getting like
what are you doing down there
but like Twitter is supposed to be a
place where you know there's a photo
there's your name like there's
accountability and it's like and still
people feel like they you know can pass
judgment I think Twitter I think Twitter
service and it's always said Twitter
people who are like calling for sponsors
and boycotts like yeah you know the
unready they just talk a lot of [ __ ] but
nothing comes out of Reddit that's
actually very true I just would like to
give an honorable mention to Facebook
like I did a facebook live years ago for
on refinery29 s page it was just all
about like building a brand and like
working with brands and doing like
content on Instagram it was like very PG
you know and it was for like the UH the
office of refinery29 but they also
livestream another Instagram and like I
had never seen a comments like that you
[ __ ] fat you I hope you [ __ ] kill
yourself writing itself over they should
have killed all you in the ovens you
know Hitler was just for fun
we're finding 29 to survive yeah it was
insane that's crazy
yes and they look like you think like
you know you have pictures of your kids
they're like what do you Hitler was
justified right you're my grandkids you
know yeah that was obviously there's no
platform that you can escape no no not
at all but I think some are worse than
others yeah I think Instagram is bad
sometimes but they they give you the
tools like to turn off comments to take
out certain words so like you could not
let anyone comment the word fat on your
picture excuse me I do that right and
like that's great also I do Jew because
just feel like abused in the word Jew
it's never really positive like if you
want to talk about Judaism or Jewish
like that's different but I've never had
anyone be like yeah beautiful Jew you
know but you know what that like that
was actually crazy is like and I forgot
where I was
heard this but the word Jew there's
actually that's what you are you are a
Jew of course people say Jewish and it
actually kind of like takes away from
the power of the word you it's like ish
and it's like people can't deal
the word G on its own no I can't carry
the worry-
right because of the other way that
other people use it but like that's the
word like I am a Jew I'm not Jewish I'm
full Jew not what is Jewish meant to
mean like I'm kind of Jewish like soy
technically no other religion I'm
Christian ish no because I I am a Jew a
Jew is a noun
I am Jewish would be adjective version I
am right and it's confusing but just
saying no other religion has an ish
that's true Christian like Buddhist no
different why wasn't it juist I don't
know Judas Judas I'm in love with Judah
it's like Jude and then they put on the
yellow star so like why would I write
it's like history keeps ruining words
for Jews that's what I'm saying
so like technically and that's white
like the fact that you block the worth
Jew because you think it's a negative
word it's like no that's the word we're
supposed to use but it's been so
tarnished
well I only I I block it because of the
adjectives that come with it usually you
know we think you dirty Jew it's never
like you smart Jew you know let's change
it let's change the narrative okay yeah
it's yes you are looking like a skinny
Jew today thank you you are one
beautiful to think I'm a glowing Jew I'm
a little sweaty you know get a little
upper lip yeah the more you show you the
voice did you that's something that will
make people uncommon final story Wendy
Williams says she's dating many men a
man Kevin hunter divorce Wendy Williams
is a true believer in the phrase the
more the merrier the talk-show host she
was in the midst of divorce from husband
Kevin hunter stop by watch what happens
live with Andy Cohen on Sunday which was
watched by girl with him a job and
thoroughly enjoyed and she revealed
she's not dating one man but several I
see many men she answered when asked if
she's still docked it's still dating the
doctor she was seeing over the summer
the 55 year old added she has age
requirements for potential partners the
youngest would be like 48 she said the
oldest would be 65 and he was really
shocked that she said she wouldn't do
younger than 48 I thought that was
shocking to like you know you're a
successful woman date who you want like
date a 35 year old but no she said she
would not date any older than 48
I mean which is very specific but has
nothing to do with success like what age
you can date it's just what you're into
yeah but it's also like when you're when
you're a successful one when you're a
successful woman you don't have to worry
about finding a partner like to steal
tablets right or like build a business
with like you just couldn't worry about
like [ __ ] whoever you want you know
yeah the freedom to it but like maybe
when you're older you only want to [ __ ]
people who are older too like it's just
it's it's a methodological way of
thinking yeah I don't think that is
suppose that's how it goes in Hollywood
right right right
um Wendy was so great on watch happens
live again the sneakers were a big miss
for me but I'm willing to look past it
um overall Jackie they were absolutely
like Bella Hadid like blends yoga then
we're like black sneakers that just her
legs looked so good and long and then
they just got like cut off by these
sneakers like it was just terrible you
also look at a picture okay um but her
and Angie were like open about they've
had like beef over the years and and he
was like we've both been messy but like
you know I just want to like be friends
they both it was like a genuine respect
they're like they just wanted to be
friends um and it was a great episode I
wish I watched the after show to see if
they even remotely discussed the Titus
and Ramadan thing but methinks no um
other than that when he's a huge
housewives fan but she is very selective
like and she said any housewife that has
ever been on her show has only been on
because we invited them like she doesn't
invite house eyes on just for the sake
of having them like she if she likes you
she'll have you on because she loves
Vicky she loves Giselle she and she
lives for Karen huger like honestly I
wasn't like dying for her choice
but you know I respect her her freedom
to choose did they ask if she'd ever go
on rioja sites there was a apparently a
rumor that she was gonna be under houses
in New York should I could trust hid in
a joking way and and he was like it's so
funny I didn't even hear the rumor until
you told me about it um she was like
joking but I feel like she actually
would I feel like she'd be great but I
think not while she's on the air it
would have to be like her second life
okay you know I hear that yeah so she
lives in New Jersey she could do Real
Housewives of New Jersey oh I don't
think she's like New Jersey vibe though
I don't know she could like teach him a
thing or two yeah but she's very New
York like does she like any of the
houses of New Jersey has she had them on
she didn't mention it but she did say
please don't give Teresa and Joe their
own show because she thinks it'll be
detrimental because it's just about
yeah and it's like they love to get
spin-offs and she was like please just
don't okay and and II agreed okay
yeah nice okay so do you want to talk
about Potomac and then we'll talk about
Kardashians
okay real houses of atomic I'm I'm new
so I'm just I'm just you know trying to
stay stay alive in and keep up and I
know like everyone hates this girl
Candace but like she is literally so
beautiful like she is this part of the
perfect hair of her husband is so cute
and like I don't know what's wrong with
her but maybe I'm like missing something
and I need to catch up on but I really
like her
Monique is good to people talk about
Monique like she's like the second
coming of Christ I'm like I don't see
that but again like maybe I miss things
I never agreed with what who people
think is the best housewives of all time
it's always like the obvious choice and
for me that's not what makes the great
housewife right and so when it comes to
Karen huger like Karen huger is in my
mind like the LVP and so as far as I
know I'm watching season one now and
she's like they're treating season one
Potomac like they did season one Dallas
like charity charity charity but instead
of charity it's all about etiquette so
it's like that it's not proper and if
you're sitting in my seat it's so stupid
I mean Karen huger is like the the you
know the dawn of the group like she
knows yeah like she knows the best
etiquette and she grew up the right way
and she she she she and and she's so
annoying and then I believe this season
she tells everyone her husband is the
black Bill Gates like literally a both
on the show and in person like she
always introduces ever everyone to her
husband has some black Bill Gates and
he's the head of this big IT company and
they this big house and some of the
ladies found out this season that um
like they have no money like it was all
this big facade like they sent a
pizza-delivery to her house and like
there was no at home like and she had to
come clean so it's like everyone still
treats her like this LVP and it's like
'no no like she lied she's fake like and
she was being so rude and judging to all
these women when like she literally was
like faking that she was living in this
house so it's just like and everyone
like TPG loves her like bought her
perfume and it's like I refuse to look
past you know right well the big lie
yeah so it's just like frustrating to
watch and then this girl Giselle who was
like it like she is a housewife VIP like
I could tell she has it in her she's
beautiful love her she was front row
attention hell yes and so she was
married actually the first episode is
very interesting
you find out about Potomac and just like
this group of women in general and
they're all like really like prestigious
in in like the black community like
Giselle's
ex-husband was like a huge civil rights
advocate like works with Martin Luther
King he's like so famous and now I think
they're back together and that's what
she was sitting with at the front row of
the Dave Chappelle special oh my god
because when we were watching it I said
to cut him like that looks like gizelle
from Potomac and you say you thought it
was a housewife
also and then we got confirmation that
it was but she had a crazy but it was
fun Atlanta and it actually makes sense
though that it should be there with her
ex-husband because he's like such a
prominent guy and takes Chapelle like
definitely no Steven like gave him
tickets you know only so it's just
there's so many layers to Potomac that I
think if anyone's gonna watch it like
watch it first season because it's
important to understand um just like
what Potomac is it's not just like a
city like it's really more of a
lifestyle and then there's this girl
Katie who who I'm watching in season
three like is such a loser like she
cannot and she's like the most beautiful
she's the youngest the tall is like
she's the biggest loser ever like she
literally can't put two words together
without starting to cry and then I'm
watching her season one and she is from
the most like rich philanthropic family
that the Ross family it's like the
biggest heel she's half Jewish
she is like a baby-naming bris for her
kids like it's it's interesting watching
now and then because this show is so
different and like the ladies obviously
like they got to like you it's
interesting to watch like when they had
nothing to lose versus now they're like
famous and they act differently and then
there was this woman Charisse on it who
was literally the worst housewife of all
time like I could have been wearin yes
yes yeah with the T Charisse was so
obnoxious like she's not on anymore I'm
so grateful and I literally couldn't say
I'm watching the show just because of
like how she talked about herself and
her husband like actually like it's
normal that her husband lives in New
Jersey oh and there's actually like a
deep connection to the NBA like almost
every single one of them I they're like
had their husband played their coach
like there's a deep NBA connection to
the Real Housewives of Potomac which I
also found to be incredibly interesting
it's just it's it's a good show the way
people talk about it like it's the best
thing ever like everyone's sleeping on
it like no I actually feel that way more
about Dallas but it's really good okay
me y'all get a shot let's talk about
Real Housewives of Kardashian's season
17 premiere last night oh no no keep it
up with the Kardashians
c17 from here last night boring episode
but again even if boring episode of the
Kardashians is an insight into the
incredibly interesting life of a rich
and famous person know a hundred percent
I feel like there's so much going on
with them that we don't know about at
all like in and her hands um an even
Chloe Tristan and the birthday party
like I just saw the birthday party
thought it was cute like whatever
there's so much drama I've really missed
watching that I missed watching them and
then anytime Courtney came on scream I
was like oh wait I don't miss watching
literally this spoiled brat crying
complain about nothing like if only
Kourtney Kardashian knew real problems
like this is what she cried about and I
just I don't understand like she she had
a emotional moment I don't understand
what she was saying like hey that's what
she was saying she was she cried on the
episode about two things one she's
having so much anxiety about a birthday
party like I don't know should I have
one [ __ ] have a birthday literally
nobody cares - and then she's crying
because her life isn't um she's having
anxiety about the fact that she doesn't
know what she wants like it was the most
vague she doesn't know what she wants
but she feels like she should because
she's turning 40 it was so weird and
then something came up about like should
she be with Scott and it's like is that
an option right that was really happy
that was a weird conversation like it
made it seem like Kourtney like has
spoken about it but just the way that I
perceive of everything that goes on and
you know you never knows what goes on
behind closed doors it's like Scott is
so happy and couldn't care less about
getting back together with Kourtney he
wanted it for so long and he didn't
think he could find happiness anywhere
else but he actually did find even
bigger better happiness outside of
Kourtney and I think he like never wants
to leave yeah and he's like still so in
the family you know he had the best of
all worlds an uncle to all the kids and
like he's still on Kardashians right and
he's still close with Kris and MJ and
Sophia is so close with Kylie and like
it's really a perfect situation except
for the fact like it's a little still
age of him ancient appropriate yeah but
you know what we're getting better
anybody getting better she turned 21 but
like let me not forget but last name was
like a real moment for me I'm like
imagine if Kourtney Kardashian had to
worry about like paying her bills but
she cannot handle the pressure of having
no problems like she was honestly it's
I'm very happy for her that she's rich
and famous because I don't think she
would be able to handle like real
problems because always she's crying and
complaining about like not existent
issues yeah or like
she had to get a job oh my god and like
[ __ ] to deal with workplace that
conflict she had to like start a company
that like had to be profitable right or
else the house goes you know right you
know she's never like she is truly the
epitome of just like a spoiled brat and
watching her like it's so worked up
genuinely like real tears over arbitrary
fake entitled 'us problems was so
frustrating especially the birthday like
that's the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever heard
like okay I miss you don't [ __ ] like
you're annoyed that people are planning
a birthday party like because you don't
like parties and you don't like people
yelling with who like don't have a party
seems easy seems easy like no it looks
like no one even wants to celebrate wait
the best part also she made Chloe make
the invitation out of that picture and I
was like making fun of how tacky it was
when it was literally her idea and she
showed it to Chloe Chloe's like oh my
god she's I can now photoshopped even
though that was the photo that went
viral of Courtney naked in the bathtub
before having three thighs yeah so she
literally said now Photoshop when we
know that it was the whole thing the
whole thing is she's delusional yeah um
and it's like annoying because she's
someone who probably realized I'm gonna
show the most like this is really her
full-time job where he's like for
everyone else it's the thing that they
do in addition to like their businesses
yep and it's like great marketing for
their businesses but like it's not their
number one job no but they know that
it's a necessary part of the ecosystem
in order for good American and k'kaw
beauty like to have this huge platform
yeah
a hundred percent but for Courtney it's
like you would think that she would be
way more interesting since literally it
is her only livelihood yeah okay and
push as well I just like want to be
watching the other girls so much more so
much more and it looks like next week
Kourtney and Kim get into a fight and if
you're like in the last three or four
seasons they've been actually a lot more
like open it used to be like really
scripted when I feel like they had a lot
more to lose from the show but now it's
like they're really in their own
stratosphere like they can use the show
in a more honest way and I feel like
they've really started to develop like a
narrative and and you really get to seem
like what goes on and there is something
between Kourtney and Kim like that I
don't I can't figure out why there's so
much contention but it's like it's
really bad it is bad but I was actually
singing last night like there's been a
few seasons now where they like yell at
each other and they've been fighting a
lot but they've never ever like publicly
turned on one another and like even
though
he's like so off the deep-end sometimes
like she isn't that out of control that
like you know she still understands I
think what's important if your family
like we're gonna make it work and she's
keeps talking about moving away and like
I feel like that would be great for if
the Kardashians ever get to a place
where some of them are publicly [ __ ]
on or turning on one another that will
be the end of their business like they
have gotten that's why the Robb thing
was so devastating like they have gotten
to where they've gotten for being this
close family unit who like people could
relate to like the family people don't
like when you like air your family's
dirty laundry it's really sad really
or like that's your whole brand like the
Pratt's right you know and it's like
okay so we're just interested in that
but like don't try and make a family
business after that yeah we're not gonna
night so it's one or the other right so
I think that they all know that like
that's the bottom line
like you can say the main things you
could be mean but you can never be cross
that line because that's where it'll
truly affect our business right so she's
never crossed that line which is like
okay she's that's true she's not that
crazy crazy but what else happen I mean
this Tristan stuff is so crazy he's like
an insane person hey Tristan coming over
trying to kiss Chloe no also like with
the non-stop calling and texting
that's just like such interesting leave
our girl alone I know she's so pretty
enough that birthday party was what like
yeah oh my god the cake the dessert
table the pressure for these parties
that looks like don't you ever just want
to happen backyard BB q I know I think
that was like their attempt at a
backyard barbecue and it's like clubs
like I'm going so over-the-top and saw
me like [ __ ] out stormy world and it was
like so much bigger and better you know
like but like do you think there's
competition within themselves probably
there's competition just for them to top
themselves but not like against one
another because I think everyone has
their own style
I've been like I think everyone
considers Chloe like cheesy but by the
way Chloe's style is like so mine know
also that likes silk she made everyone
wear plenty vibes like no like I thought
it was so lazy that most of her but like
Kim has her very own way of doing things
she doesn't relate you at all I don't
think Chloe relates to it but Kim
doesn't relate to me there's not real
competition and I'm like
is just on another level right no one
compares themselves to her so actually
things like it works really well but
what was the party that they had where
they took that sister photo it was like
in the backyard this is like where they
looked beautiful was recently and I
think it was like MJ's birthday yeah
they had a backyard vbq recently that
was pretty low-key because you know
what's so crazy it's like their regular
family dinner is a backyard maybe with
like chefs and waiters and they sit
outside and it's all cooked but so that
could never be a party cuz that's
literally just there's so many people
they have to satisfy but when when with
choose actual booze cruise true birthday
so you know the cousins came over and
they had cake I'm like that's our
birthday like that's the party that is
that's what we would that's what I would
consider a birthday party but like
that's not enough yeah I know that that
was so cute and they were all singing
happy birthday like and honestly some of
the kids are starting to look so much
like like stormy and Chicago like I
cannot develop the triplets
so we're me Chicago true they were boy
but I could tell true like crew true is
so [ __ ] cute she looks unique like
and truths developing her own style I
okay she loves a turbo she's no one can
wear a turban now without looking like
Thompson yeah she Jackson yeah yeah well
turban with a little toasty print we
need to get a picture of keke palmer and
true thompson like it's too much it's
too much true okay also I need to talk
to you about something did you know and
I can't believe there wasn't a story
about it I mean never reported on it
because it's local Morning Show news
keke palmer is now a third co-host of
Strahan and Sarah I know that because we
were just talking about it I only know
because I saw it in a cab and I know
because you saw in the cabin you texted
me about it how weird very weird I think
they're just trying new things over
there I thought they chant I thought
they did it as like a week guest host
like to promote hustlers for her then
they like change the logo they changed
it Instagram I'm like wait no this is
real so it's Strahan Sarah and Kiki I
don't know that name I think yeah yeah
by the way and honestly now it's just
really highlighting how much Tara's
gotta go because like Strahan eki like
have this vibe to them right and the key
key is like so it I like don't know who
Sarah is I know I know I don't know who
Sarah is in this trio like I knew who
she was with oh who oh no I'm saying I
do not know how she is she's like an NBC
girl come into the room and
I would've you know she's wanted like
the revolving door of NBC talent who is
there like to be like the anchor like
ever like Strahan and Kiki get to be fun
and like you know everyone loves them
but Strahan is very like he is real
hosting he said I don't think I need him
I don't know but that's how I feel about
Daley pop like Chrissa Justin and Morgan
like it is imperative that they already
are there and like I know that Chris is
technically like the most boring one but
like she holds it down though that
Justin and Morgan can shine and it
wouldn't be the same if it was like
three fun bubbly people maybe I just
think it's a weird format like to have a
guest on talking to three people do you
know what I mean yeah it's over watch it
on daily pop it so they only talk to two
people right I'm gonna take someone
leaves takes a break yeah if they're
like not interested interesting I just
thought it was like an interesting
morning show move and they didn't make
any waves about it well I know like keke
palmer is a morning show host like what
can't she do do you think sara is like
having a breakdown then she finally got
our own show and like now some kid is
taking over and like doing better I mean
probably because like what an you like
hear about all these things after the
fact it turns out like everyone hated
each other all along but you know
thinking optimistically it's like oh
well we're getting like True Jackson on
our show like our stock is about to rise
like she should be excited you know for
like the youthquake
that Kiki that's the thing but no one
thinks I am and Sarah is an interesting
show because it's very similar
demographic wise to the toast like they
interview Bachelor people not
demographic oh I said content wise yeah
and it doesn't make a lot of sense for
like Strahan and Sarah to be talking to
Raven gates like do you know any mean
like they don't know her and she don't
know them like keke palmer was a
refreshing new fresh younger face and it
made a lot of sense like because they
are like a spin-off of The Today Show
but they're very much like for people
our age which is great but it doesn't
make a lot of sense have Michael Strahan
and that girl Sarah like talking about
The Bachelor like they don't know they
don't watch The Bachelor you know I
think they're like working through we're
watching them figure it rain storm you
know and like figuring out what works
okay I just thought it was something we
had to discuss that it's pertinent
morning show news right and nobody was
talking about it
speaking of morning show news I watched
the trailer for the morning show that TV
show and Apple with Jennifer Aniston and
Reese Witherspoon and honestly it looks
really good
I'm really excited cheating they'll need
houses like consultants
III think so like I could feel they were
missing that like Millennials right you
know yeah
sense it radiating yeah so we're
available something to think about
we're about two thousand dollars an hour
for consulting so yeah I hope they can
afford us cheap mmm
anything else that we needed to recap TV
kim kardashian you know what i watch
yesterday falling in love okay I'll
watch it today I know we kept tomorrow
okay can I just keep like my overall my
review like from a one to ten
considering everyone said it was like at
an eleven okay you talk tomorrow about
it cuz I don't want to like have
preconceived notions I know I'm gonna
say everyone says said it's like a ten
eleven it's an eight I would say seven
okay [ __ ] okay but like I'm so here for
it and then I downloaded apparently
there's like a more premium hallmark app
that I didn't have and that has like all
the hallmark movies and soap falling in
love really like made me in the mood to
watch more love stories like that and
now I'm in such a great place content
wise like I have movies for days
watching one with Minka Kelly and anemic
McDowell right now exciting it's so good
Chad Michael Murray what's the name of
the app it's called the beach house
okapis hallmark movies but it's just
$4.99 a month okay anyone at crown media
like wants to combat for me like look
into your account oh [ __ ] I don't think
you can stream out more than one [ __ ] am
I gonna use it for that yes sir yeah um
okay I think that's it I think that's
all she wrote
well this episode was brought to you by
skims and Thank You Kim for trusting us
with with your life and for putting the
premium content honestly I got so many
messages like people are evil okay ready
people [ __ ] evil because the next
morning I put a screenshot of you on
Kim's story and I was like can you
believe and I got like so many messages
like do people think I'm so vo they're
like you're so [ __ ] radiating with
jealousy like you're disgust I was like
excuse your sister Jackie isn't
everything and you are nothing you are
disgusting evil GLI and I was like
excuse me I just I was just trying to
like put up an Instagram like so crazy I
know they're like you're just jealous
that your fat ugly eyes didn't make it
like Jackie did I'm like okay well
that's true but that's so great no I saw
like one thing where people were like
tryin to start somethin
it's like we were on the phone the whole
night you know who's trying to start
stuff
Ben let me get me a jack on the phone
the whole time like trying to figure out
like how to handle this huge PR moment
for the time right just like freaking
out and we hang up and Ben's like
touching he's like it's it's okay
I'm like I'm fine I really was found
like your story first so I really and I
know nobody believes me but like I
really was fine I believe you because I
was talking to I was really so happy for
you and like honestly I did not like
want to be on I did not want to put on
the leotard
like I just I could have put my big fat
ass out there and like maybe you know I
did one photo and it looks really you
know face tuned and edited like I just
whatever I really was so happy like
genuinely and I really was not jealous
like we got the toast out there like
that's what we're trying to do your
videos were better and like you look
better in the skins like everyone was
like I got so many messages like ugly
fat I'm not jealous like I'm genuinely
like was so happy for you like I was
like in the toaster she was like
freaking out I can vouch for you that
you were happy for me because I was
talking to her all [ __ ] night yeah
but like Ben and Instagram were like
really coming for me like trying to make
me seem jealous they're trying to stop
and let Jill get me wrong like I'm
jealous of literally everything you have
but like I really wasn't jealous no it's
like a little jealous like of course
like nothing like such a pernicious way
evil way just like really genuinely like
I was so happy for you know totally
people you guys are a wild yeah I think
Ben was jealous and he was he was
started projecting yeah because he put
the bra on like he wasn't right he was
being so they're so he's like put me on
the story I'm like honestly it was
really funny she shouldn't repost him
but it caught it like whatever it's all
good maybe Kim already possess whatever
we got what we needed Kim's coming on
the toast like eventually and that's all
that really matters they came has seen
the words the morning toast because of
you step 1 thank you so one complete
phase two an hour show without air
conditioning we are truly medical
marvels yeah naked Marco thank you so
much for watching the morning tow
similarly millennial Morning Show
endorsed by Kim Kardashian we are a
millennial Morning Show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so feel free to give
this video a thumbs up a smiley a
comment a subscribe we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast we found
so that's I don't know
Apple Spotify iTunes tickets to my tour
that are the jeans to are available to
girl with no job calm come an awesome
Friday they were going to ban cougar hit
in Seattle we're going to LA San
Francisco San Diego all the West Coast
hit it up tickets girl walk available
girl no job calm anything you want to
say yes please tell me I check you go
problems because I'm like pretty close
to 21 and then will like cap it off
therefore now I get my presets Jack
yellow calm and have a great day
everyone we'll see you tomorrow
you